Okay.
I'm going to talk about religion today.
Um,
yeah.
And,
and what,
I'm going to first law talk just a little bit about people who weren't born into
the Catholic church.
The vast majority of the population of France at the time in the course until
um,
until I say 1960,
we're born a Catholic now whether they practice their religion is something will
come to a,
in a minute,
um,
of the percentage of the population of France who were Protestants,
which I'll talk a little bit about minute.
It's about 5%.
The number of Jews I think chips,
Roi and tells you in his book,
but I think it's about 300,000.
Now.
First let me tell you where Protestants and Jews were for the most part and why.
Just to give you a sense of all this,
um,
the,
the reformation in the 16th century,
uh,
when it sort of Calvinism expands from,
from Geneva.
Um,
whereas you don't caravan I had considerable influence.
Uh,
it's spread really down,
uh,
down the Rhone River.
I,
and it,
it conquered large parts are found adepts in large parts of this part of France,
including Leone Leone was conquered,
backed by the Catholic Church as they would consider it,
the Catholic reformation,
or it used to be called the counter reformation,
but you don't call it that anymore.
Um,
but yet there were large sections of the south of France that remained
Protestant and that still are just in case it ever pops up in a crossword
puzzle.
Uh,
the department with the largest number of Protestants,
something that's like a third,
it's about what it was in the,
uh,
in the 19th century is the gap,
the Ga rd,
uh,
that you would,
I've,
that's where Neem is the capital of it.
Um,
and the second is the Aldes shut a,
which is where we hang out.
Um,
they're also still and were Protestants,
uh,
in the vet river valleys.
We're coming down to the Rhone,
particularly in the department of the dome.
I mean,
you don't have to remember all this information.
Lots of Protestants in Lohan and in El Sauce.
And of course that had been amputated in the next to Germany.
And you know,
Protestant serve here and there,
lots of Protestants,
uh,
when the edict of not that is,
it gave toleration to Protestantism has revoked by Louis the 14th in 1685.
Uh,
lots of people tried to get out,
uh,
lots of Huguenots as they were called.
I went to Amsterdam,
to the pay Ba to Netherlands,
uh,
and lots try to go to Quebec in Canada because it would be,
they slaughtered,
be easier to practice their religion there,
but many of them couldn't afford the passage and ended up living here in the
Shank to they're in the shock Mary team in this area here.
The shot haunt for you.
That's the beautiful city,
Francis most beautiful city on the coast outside of [inaudible],
a La Rochelle,
uh,
the capital of the shrimp and met the team.
Um,
and then you have Protestants of course,
in,
in Paris and in some of the large,
uh,
cities.
Uh,
what happens is after the annexation of,
of Alsace and much of lower end by,
uh,
by the German empire,
many of the Protestants in,
in l I'll sauce and some in little hen moved,
uh,
many move to,
to better for,
uh,
which it became a territory because of they're not a department because of their
heroic defense of bell for by a general during the Franco Prussian war.
So there are your,
your main centers of Protestantism.
Now what about Jews who get right during the French Revolution,
the first synagogue,
uh,
in France,
which is,
you know,
routinely targeted by,
vicious graffiti and this sort of thing,
uh,
is in the Volcker lose that as they pop them all of Avignon a place called a
Coffee Cup and saucer competence.
You can see either say either we're trusts usually and a cup and costumes.
And the other side of the Rhone,
I you have large concentrations of Jews and Sephardic Jews in Boldo,
uh,
and in Paris and in Alsace and Lorraine were there,
had been really vigorous and vicious antisemitic riots,
uh,
after the revolution of 1848.
And in Alsace,
interestingly enough,
the three religions that as the Catholics,
the Protestants and the Jews tried to outdo each other in charity.
They said it really remarkable kind of voluntary associations to help up poor
people.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
as for one interesting sort of aspect of it.
So that's just a sort of overview,
but the vast majority of the population,
we're born in to the Catholic church now because of the role of the church in
the counterrevolution of the great French Revolution.
And because of the close attachment of the Catholic church to monitor,
to,
to uh,
the monarch,
to the monarchy that his support for the ill fated Quanta Shamba Henry the fifth
and all of that.
You have this tension,
uh,
between the Catholic Church as a public institution and,
an increasingly powerful state.
Now one differentiation that you should make.
Eye is a between D Christianization,
which I'm going to talk about and anti clericalism.
Now,
Voltaire,
the great philosophic,
he once said,
crush the awful thing and he didn't mean religion itself.
What he met with the public institutional role of the Catholic Church and he
was,
became the ultimate sort of symbol of,
of anti clericalism.
Anti clericalism wasn't necessarily antilope religiosity.
What it was was,
was against the public role institutional role of the Catholic church in
politics,
Vus in French cities in the 1850,
the 1880s and nineties.
There are literally battles over urban space where lay,
lay,
assize secularized and anticlerical municipalities want to refuse the rights of
uh,
or the right of cat,
the Catholic Church to stage processions of relics,
for example,
on,
on feast days in the most,
which became Levine,
who's a,
you know,
a red,
the red city.
Uh,
it had once been a very religious town,
but they still have this every seven years.
They still do these perceptions where they haul state,
uh,
saints relics through the streets.
And so the Mississippi [inaudible],
they said,
no,
you can't do that because that is violating the neutrality of public space.
And so that's,
you have this big bigeye he got this big brawl between a church and,
you know,
lay a sizing secularizing municipalities influenced by,
by socialism,
uh,
and not necessarily against religion,
but against the public role of,
of the Catholic Church.
And so that's kind of,
you know,
a background go for all of that.
Now.
It used to be maybe 80 years ago,
no less than that,
maybe 50 years ago,
that,
um,
one of the,
the,
the interpretations of the French Revolution and the impact of the French
revolution and the empire,
the first empire that is an one Napoleon,
the first who made peace with the church was that it was the revolution that
destroyed that old time religion.
And in 1815 when Louie the 18th,
before this course cranks up,
comes back.
Um,
he,
he espouses the view that,
that,
that church people had,
that the revolution,
uh,
had been created by people like,
Ooh,
so,
and Voltaire and that they had been responsible for moving France away from that
old time religion.
And as I said the other day after 1815,
there's a revival of,
of intense religiosity in some regions.
You find the same thing in,
uh,
in the 1870s,
again,
the Republic of the moral order.
And so that's what the church wanted people to believe.
And many historians believe that as well.
But along came a historian called Michelle Vavera,
v O.
V e l l e used to be the professor of the French Revolution in the Sorbonne.
And he's kind of a friend of mine,
or at least a good of Quinton's,
a very old dude now.
Um,
and Volvo was interested to see whether that old time religion was a already
crumbling or in decline before the French revolution.
And so he started asking just how effective was the counter reformation or the
Catholic reformation,
if you will,
in bringing back reviving that broke piety of a religion,
of faith,
of religion in paintings of swooning cupid's of intense religious belief.
And what he discovered was that in the parts of France that he looked at that
that old time religion was already waning.
And thus we come to the concept which is important for this course.
And just in general of d Christianization and d Christianization means two
things.
First,
again,
before this course,
it meant the campaign against the church has a public institution and really
against organized religion undertaken by a,
during the terror,
by Robespierre and the others.
It meant melting down church bills.
It Ma admit meaning that,
that only priests who swore allegiance to the French revolution to the nation
could say mass.
And pretty soon putting them under pressure,
not to say mass at all,
but that's not what we're talking about.
The residuals,
the remnants of that are still important in the period where we're discussing.
But what Volvo Bell,
whose name I should write on the board,
uh,
in a book called broke piety and d Christianization,
which is looking at part of,
of uh,
privas started with that.
What he had meant was that decline in religious practice.
Now it's very hard.
And before imagine you're in a store and that's what you are in this course.
How are you going to prove whether religion has that has still an important role
in the individual person or in family life or in public life?
If you're looking along time ago,
how are you going to know that in a society in which in the,
in the 18th century,
uh,
the majority of people could not read and write and in which the only things
about religion that you could read were reports written by or sermons written
by,
published by bishops and archbishops or reports sent by those delegates of
bishops and archbishops going around France.
Uh,
I were going around there,
their diocese to see how many,
uh,
and what the state of religion was.
How do you do that?
How do you know what,
you know,
whether people went to church or not,
how do you know that?
And so what he did was the following the,
and this was talking about tough work,
uh,
that their ways of doing this.
Uh,
let me just give you a couple of,
for example,
I don't know how some of you raised Catholic.
I was raised Catholic.
I was once thrown out of a religion class and paddled [inaudible] Jesuit high
school in Portland,
Oregon.
Uh,
because,
uh,
the guy had messed up the Thomas Aquinas's proofs of the existence of God.
And I thought,
I thought it was a smart ass.
I could prove that God couldn't exist by what he'd done.
And so they,
they threw me out of religion class.
Uh,
uh,
but you know,
so I don't know if that would be a statistic in,
in,
in this kind of evolution,
but basically what,
uh,
in the Catholic Church,
babies ha have had to be,
I don't know if it's still the case,
but it had to be baptized,
uh,
within the first three days of birth.
Just thus all these,
these certificates that have,
remember that the act of Tim One oz where people say,
I,
I see this baby.
The baby is alive and they baptize the baby if the baby dies and member babies
died all the time.
I,
after childbirth,
if you've made it to one year,
one,
you had a good chance of living to the ripe old age of 40,
uh,
that,
you know,
if you didn't baptize the baby,
the baby died and the baby,
you know,
uh,
was going to go to limbo or something sort of float around all these,
these popular beliefs of a,
about limbo.
And so what he did is he went out and he looked at all of these baptism
certificates of baptism,
SoundLens of them to see how long it was that,
you know,
how long did people back to after the birth that they baptize their children.
And now people had already started thinking about that.
The first religious sociologists were priests at the end of the 19th century who
said,
people don't go to church anymore.
Why not?
And so they,
they went out and they began to effect one of the people who people,
people whose work I most admire is an old,
very old,
it must be 110 and we literally 90 a priestly most who used to go out and look
in the cemeteries to see what people had written on tombs.
And he looked at the names that people named babies.
More about that in a minute.
So what Volvo found in what subsequent historians of religion have found are,
are that,
you know,
the curve goes something like this,
three days to,
you know,
a month to two months to six months.
And in the 19th century,
increasingly in parts of France,
that's key.
Never.
Um,
and then there are other things you could do when people of means died.
They left wills in,
in 1830s in Paris,
75% of the population left nothing to nobody because he had nothing to leave
anybody and they couldn't afford to have anybody drop a will.
They couldn't afford a lawyer or a notary to draw up a will.
So what Volvo found was that,
that where people had,
you know,
had,
or in earlier times at the height of the counter reformation or the Catholic
reformation in the 17th century,
they had left money to have masses said for their souls or they'd left money to
Catholic institutions.
Uh,
carrying four lepers are caring for other sick people,
uh,
or foundling homes.
And increasingly they stopped doing that in the areas that he looked at and they
started leaving money to lay associations or to somebody else,
you know,
to their uncle or their children.
I no longer,
you know,
150 masses said on their anniversary or their birthday for the repose of their
mortal soul.
And then you can look at religious vocation.
I,
there are parts of France that have always had a lot of priests.
Um,
if you needs to have,
uh,
Brittany,
for one example,
but so you could look,
and what he discovered was that the number of people going into the clergy,
men and women declined rapidly in the parts of Provence that he looked at.
Now that's a good sign.
What about names?
There's another one.
I mean,
this is a talk about boring work,
but this is what this guy normally most did.
Um,
you can,
when people start naming their babies,
when they stopped naming them after saints,
that tells you something.
For example,
in the limousine,
and this is an example,
but in the Leemoo Zack,
you know that the saints that were big time saints there,
one is a Leo.
Nah,
like Leonard and another was a [inaudible].
The name Must Yada.
And so this guy I looked in and people stop naming their children [inaudible]
and Leonard Leo now and,
and the,
and that,
you know,
that tells you something too.
Or I mean a more obvious one would be women's names.
Uh,
you made,
but you probably don't know.
People named Mary Magdalen.
Uh,
and,
and during the French Revolution,
a lot of people took the old Roman names and he started naming their babies and
things like [inaudible] and names like that.
But you can look a,
you don't know what even named Graca us.
I bet.
But you can,
uh,
you know,
this was another way that,
that you could do it.
And there's other ways to remember I said that one of the published sources you
can actually read a are these bishops sermons because they were published every
year.
And when these bishops sermons,
and I'm talking more about the 19th century when they talked to start talking
about the dark secrets,
what are the dark secrets at a time of plunging birth rate,
birth control,
birth control.
And that tells you something in a way,
very indirectly as well.
And what about even going to mass in the Catholic Church?
You're supposed to go to mass on Sundays and you're certainly supposed to go to
mass and confession,
uh,
on Easter at Easter time.
And so that's one of the things they had the priest count up.
They would count people and,
and uh,
who were in the church and what you had is again,
in astonishing decline of the number of people going to church.
Just an aside,
because I worked with a sociologist and the first thing I,
I didn't have a job when you're first year after I finished my degree.
You know what Michigan Mighty Michigan maize and blue forever.
Uh,
uh,
I taught sociology.
Uh,
and so I was used to counting things.
You know,
I worked out with a great sociologist called Charles.
And so one day,
cause I was writing a book about our religion and uh,
with my daughter then who was about 11,
I,
we heard the bells ring for church and there's only a mass about every six
weeks.
More about that later.
And I said,
well,
let's go up and count the number of people in Church.
So,
and there's a huge gap between men and women in a church attendance.
It was true in the 19th century,
and it's true now.
So we go to the back of this church and we start counting the number of people
and there were 18 people and my daughter,
then 11,
all of us and said,
may the fom sown Shoaff even the,
even the women are bald.
And of course then everybody in the church turned around and looked at us
standing in the back.
Uh,
and she had an accrual point there.
She didn't mean to be cruel,
but it was at most of the people who went to church were very old ladies.
Uh,
but the priest even now and this particular village does not have a regular
priests and has not had for decades.
They count the number of people who are there on Easter.
And what you had is this precipitous decline in,
uh,
in the number of people going to church.
So that is deep Christianization.
Let me give you another example from World War One war memorials.
Many of you have had my friend.
Some of you may have had my friend Jay winters course and he works at his,
done a lot of work on war memorials.
And if you go to parts of France that were very Christianized,
more about this later,
if you go to the,
to the [inaudible] are up here to the end,
the Africa here or the Rda,
those are classic examples of very Christianized parts of France.
Even the war memorials were in some places where you practiced religion,
the warm,
the number of the monument to the dead will be near the church in some of those
places.
The monument to the dad is not only not near the church that no one goes to,
but we'll have a broken cross asking that same question that Voltaire went to
ask about that Lisbon earthquake.
If there was a god,
how could he or she have allowed this to happen?
And even those monuments are symbols of,
of,
of uh,
of a decline in what had been assumed by the church and indeed assumed by the
state of that old time religion.
But now is this true everywhere?
Well,
no,
not at all.
And that's one of the points.
And that's one of the reasons that I insisted.
If you don't have one,
please come up and get one later.
Those handy little maps with the regions and they did it,
pop them all because there are huge differences and these differences were
already apparent.
Uh,
in,
uh,
18th century.
The French Revolution was above all the civil war,
a war about religion.
And if you take a map from 1789 or 1790,
90,
when the priest had to either swear to the nation to the French revolution or
refuse to swear to the revolution and to the nation,
and you take that map and you put it along a map of the elections of,
of May,
1849 and you put that on top of a map of the election of phosphor meeting hall
as President of France of 1981.
They're are almost the same with very few changes.
And one of the predictors here,
I sound like a sociologist,
which I am not,
but one of the predictors of all of that is the Christianization because the
regions of political conservatism are the regions in which that old time
religion was in which those reasons were less d Christianized than other places.
So where were the d Christianized,
uh,
regions?
Where were the religions of the areas of still intense religious practice?
Just for the hell of it.
Uh,
oh,
Vanya again.
Oh,
van.
Yeah,
that's a region you shouldn't,
you know,
you should at least know something about if you like astronomy,
you'll think of Audi,
go fabulous garlic with potatoes or your,
you'll think of a,
you know,
stuffed cabbage,
I think of all sorts of stuff.
Uh,
but,
uh,
that's not what we're talking about.
Uh,
in Ovaria,
uh,
you still have intense religiosity.
We had a have friends who wants to own a cafe across from the national archives
where I spend quite a lot of time in both institutions.
Um,
and they,
uh,
the wife was from the Avian Wall,
which is way down here,
Mijo and all of that.
Uh,
and the husband is from contact,
which is a pure or Yak there.
And they had 13 and 12 brothers and sisters respectively,
born in abject misery in the 1930s just misery classic.
Some of the babies died,
but that's a lot of children.
Now if you compare that,
if you go about,
if you want to drive about not even a day,
you get down here near Isiah,
uh,
the prune capital of France and one of the rugby capitols of France.
Uh,
it was sad and it was true that if,
and I mentioned this the first day,
I think that if you had more,
if you had a second child in some villages,
you received a condolence card,
a condolence card.
Now how different that is,
and those are places don't know,
aren't very far away.
Well,
the look they go on down here is extremely Decriss tonight,
whereas,
oh,
van,
you know,
one of the things the Catholic Church said was no dark secrets baby and have
lots of children and some the younger ones into the clergy as sisters and nuns
and that sort of stuff.
Uh,
other areas of religious practice in El Sauce,
Catholics,
Protestants and Jews all practice their religion very faithfully in the north of
France,
particularly in the Flemish parts of the north.
That old time religion was still practiced in much of Normandy.
The same thing though,
not in big cities,
less than,
less than Raul for example.
And in Brittany,
uh,
above all,
religion was practiced as it always had been.
And there were huge numbers of people going on if they call them Brittany,
the pardons,
which are,
you know,
religious ceremonies full of festivity as well.
Now,
what are the big D Christianized areas?
Almost any large city,
even in the case of,
of Brittany breasts because it had so many sailors who weren't from Brittany.
There are though a lot of Britain's were sailors also,
for example,
in life are,
there are lots of buttons live in La.
But anyway,
that's,
it makes things more complicated than they are.
Um,
uh,
most big cities,
some exceptions.
Lele is still fairly,
uh,
practicing a Catholic,
Paris totally lost to the church.
One of the things,
if you'll,
if you go to the suburbs of Paris,
even the inner suburbs that were annexed in 1860,
you'll see all of these extremely modest and sometimes just impossibly ugly
churches that were built in the 1870s to try to reconquer the pie,
the working class population that had been lost in the working class suburbs to
the Catholic Church sock record,
which I've already denounced because of his art architecture.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
standing on my match for the beauty of Beaut,
beaut of Mamacita was there as a sign of pennants because of,
of the Franco Prussian war,
but the cities were basically lost to the Catholic church with some exceptions,
but so we're huge regions.
Uh,
the,
the false,
the area around Paris here,
the eating of the false as this call because you can imagine,
and it's kind of vaguely as an island because of all these rivers,
uh,
extremely deep Christianize the Leemoo that around the Moje totally the
Christianized to southwest.
Absolutely.
I forgot to mention that we're,
Bernadette have lured,
saw the Virgin Mary,
that that part of the Pyrenees was still very Christianized prevalence,
much of provost,
uh,
very,
d Christianized as well.
Um,
and as I said before,
you know,
the Board Monet,
I mean you don't have to know these regions just to know that you know something
about the big ones.
So there are big regional disparities in this.
And the,
this is background to the separation of the church and state a of church and
state in 1905 and to the various law as you can read it and sour wines,
books,
uh,
the anticlerical legislation that really starts in 1878,
1879,
they will lead to expulsion of,
of some of the religious orders and eventually that decoupling of church and
state in 1905.
Now this to be sure is a rather pessimistic from the point of view of the church
assessment and perhaps overly self because there has been recent work that has
described,
uh,
in many parts of,
of France and in part parts of their Catholic Germany.
Also a revival of intense religiosity that has a lot to do with miracles.
Now in the Catholic Church,
uh,
you know,
in bad times,
sometimes miracles come along to kind of rescue the church.
And the case of Bernadette have lured before this course in 1856 was one of it.
I mean,
Lord becomes one of the first tourist sites in France after Paris because these
all,
it's always young girls by the way,
always who see the Virgin Mary never young boys is always young girls.
That's interesting case.
A Mar Penguin and the SAR and what 1876 up here in Germany,
two comes along at a good time for the Catholic Church or Fatima in Portugal in
1917.
It's always young illiterate shepard girls who see the Virgin Mary.
And then what happens is they interview them,
they bring translators to interview them as in the case of Bernadette,
what did you see?
And they stick to their stories and pretty soon,
you know,
their bishops are little skeptical and then they seize upon the moment.
And this becomes the,
you know,
God is telling us something that we have sin in the Virgin Mary is looking after
us.
So it,
it revives,
it happened also in the 1830 is near Granola or is that the forties a place
called Las [inaudible]?
Uh,
it is sort of a sort of classic.
And then,
uh,
as I said the other day talking about the railroads,
I mean the first,
and for many people,
only railroad trip they ever took.
People that,
you know,
in the 1870s in 1882 didn't have a lot of money,
is to wear,
to learn,
to get,
uh,
you know,
to,
to if they're sick,
to try to be healed or to buy holy water.
I just saw something the other day that they had a big confrontation and an
airport because they refuse to let him carry holy water.
On the plane because it was bigger than a mini tube of toothpaste.
You know,
they,
how they take away,
you can only have little bottles instead of big bottles and it will even happen
on the,
you know,
on a paypal airplane or something like that.
I mean,
so this,
we live in a very different world now.
They didn't have to worry about that stuff at the time of these miracles.
But pilgrimages to Lou [inaudible] from every diocese in France.
It's still something that you see,
uh,
all the time.
But regional,
these regional outlines remain very,
very true.
Uh,
indeed.
So in 1905,
what happens is the church and the state get separated that the clergy are going
to be pretty much left on their own now,
uh,
that,
the state has control over a religious buildings.
Uh,
and this is bad news for priests and for nuns.
Now when I,
I've,
I admitted one thing when I was talking about their religious revival,
and this is something that goes very,
it goes back to the early,
well not early days,
but it goes back at least to the 16th century.
And probably earlier if I knew yes,
earlier,
earlier than that,
it goes back to the medieval period.
Now.
The Roman Catholics view of women had left them pretty much in a state of
subordination.
And that's always pretty much been the case.
I went to a school that was,
uh,
you know,
the,
the Jesuit schools I said that only it was mostly sports and it only had,
and that's kind of what I did.
Uh,
and,
uh,
it,
it didn't have women.
I mean,
that was a,
they were just out there somewhere.
And we used to like,
like to go to,
uh,
you know,
be all I figured managing me isn't a failed altar.
Boy,
you're looking at one.
But we used to like to go out to the,
to the girls school,
you know,
and,
and help the priest with the mass and in all that,
just to,
how to have a look at these women who we had basically never seen,
uh,
before.
But one of the things that happens,
it happened in the Catholic Church very early,
uh,
is that every time there's a new kind of spurt of,
of religious adherence and belief is that convents,
female convents,
the religious orders are one of the places,
one of the only places that,
that,
that women smart,
uh,
upwardly mobile women can rise and have careers worthy of their intelligence and
organizational skills if you think about it.
And so it's easy looking back,
you know,
from our secular age and kind of dissing all these people,
mumbling up in the mountains someplace or are not speaking at all in some cases,
uh,
and just,
you know,
simply praying all the time.
But what is often forgotten is for women who couldn't possibly,
you know,
Eh,
do,
do more than simply bare children and do the best they could in those
circumstances.
Because the struck the strictures of society didn't give them opportunity.
These convents actually have an important role in their lives that is often
simply forgotten.
And,
and,
and the role of,
of,
of women teachers,
even though many of them were barely educated,
uh,
you know,
in very many parts of France that were still practicing,
like are part of France,
uh,
was,
it was extremely important.
And they had what they called,
they don't call obviously grandfather rules,
but he had essentially grandmother rules,
a phrase they didn't use that meant that these teachers who are female teachers
who were nuns,
who were allowed,
we're allowed to teach in the public schools until they died.
And they were given that dignity to be able to stay and teach there.
And their teaching was valued,
uh,
for,
you know,
what,
what's,
you know,
what they did.
Uh,
and so again,
what one has to,
you know,
has to keep all of these things in,
in,
in perspective and for,
for example,
there's a woman,
a friend of mine who did a book a very long time ago,
which feminists just mall,
they couldn't stand it.
But it's a very important book because what she looked as at [inaudible],
her upper class ladies in the north,
such as those people you're going to read about in Jimmy now.
So that's a nice transition,
a vaguely nice transition.
And that one of the things that they were able to do because of their intense
religiosity was organized their own households in ways that they wanted to with
crucifixes and statues of the Virgin Mary and all this kind of stuff,
and that they carved off their own separate sphere,
uh,
and participate in their charitable activities.
So from the point of view of the Catholic church or for religiosity in general,
religious practice,
all the news is not bad,
but indeed most of it was.
Um,
and it's,
you know,
having wouldn't said what I've said,
it's easy for you to,
to,
if I ask you this to say in what regions,
where people mad as hell about the separation of church and state and,
and about the inventories that followed in 1906,
you would already know the answer.
Now.
What were the inventories,
the inventories where they sent some state inspector round who's going to say,
we're going to look at all the paintings in this church and to assess their
value.
Now,
even in very modest villages have almost no means a,
they all had some sort of paintings,
often just terrible art.
Uh,
but you know,
you never know.
Maybe you're going to stagger into a Rubens or something like that purely by
accident on the border of,
of,
of slanders,
of Belgium.
You don't know that.
And so they send around these specter,
the,
these,
these inspectors and in many cases the faithful lock themselves in the church.
They barricade the church and then they have to bring soldiers in.
And this looks kind of bad that soldiers are camping in fields near the church.
Then they have to conscript locksmiths from the towns to come and force open the
lock.
And in many cases that doesn't work.
So they have to bring people with huge access.
So again,
from the point of view of the church,
this is the martyrdom of Sassy bastion.
Again,
this is the martyrdom of ordinary people.
At the hands of accrual secularizing centralized state,
working against the interests of,
of ordinary religious people.
Now,
to be sure that the Catholic Church had not done itself any great favors with
the paypal syllables of errors in 19 in 1864 that said that modernity don't
liberalism,
democracy,
helping workers,
anything was bad and it made the church look pretty ridiculous.
And also there was a huge controversy then over a papal pronouncement in 1871,
uh,
that said that when the pope puts on a certain hat that he is infallible,
infallible.
Now we don't pay attention to this.
Now.
Nobody pays attention to this.
Now I guess I did completely forgotten about it.
Uh,
but at that time,
what the pope puts on a certain hat and says,
you will be excommunicated and burn in hell forever if you vote for a liberal or
a socialist.
Well,
ah,
so what's that going to do?
So the church didn't do itself any favors in being provocative,
but by night,
by 1905,
1906,
the Catholic church in the wake of the Dreyfus affair,
more about that.
Another time where the Catholic Church went after Dreyfus,
uh,
who it was better than he'd be guilty,
even if he wasn't guilty because he was a Jew.
Uh,
by then you've had this rally,
Rally Mall or rallying of the Church to the republic as an institution.
And so things should have been better when they go around and knock on the door
and try to get into these churches.
But they weren't,
and people barricade themselves into these churches.
And so I got interested in this and for example,
in our particular village,
one of the things that people told were passed down generation after generation
is that the troops had been bivouacked in the field behind the new church,
which had been started in 1896 to replace the old Romanesque church,
which is disaffected or if it does affect a,
whatever you call it,
taken out of commission right across from where we live actually.
And that the church had come,
I mean that the troops had come with axes and had broken down the doors of the
church and that people had gone home with pieces of the door,
cherishing them as you would a piece of the True Cross and what Christ was
crucified.
And this was handed down from generation to generation.
And people talked about it as if they had been there.
Even folks who had been,
hadn't been to church and in ages and ages.
Now I got interested in this it because I was writing a book about this place.
And so I went to all the archives of course,
and I went to all the newspapers,
the Catholic newspaper and two and very anticlerical socialist newspaper.
And I read the accounts of all the incidents in which that happened in all of
these other villages in this part of France,
in which tensions between Protestants and Catholics had always been very high
because of the wars of religion in the 16th century,
17th century,
and in the 18th century.
And what I discovered was that the event never happened.
It never happened that there were no troops ever bivouacked outside of the
church in this particular village called Bella Zoo.
And that there was never a time that the door was bashed down by soldiers with,
uh,
with axes to look at the modest paintings on the walls of this poor church who's
parishioners had almost nothing.
The event never happened.
It did not happen.
But the,
it nonetheless,
the imagine and her in there,
you know,
in there the constitution of their memory,
it had a place which is that they were defending their church against these
forces from the outside rather than like the case of our school that they
couldn't control.
So it had a place there,
even though it never happened.
It could have happened,
but it just didn't,
it never happened.
So what's the point of all that?
Is that the separation of church and state was extraordinarily wrenching in
areas that were not Decriss denies though there were incidents in some of the
other ones as well,
and that people simply got by as best they could,
they could in,
uh,
the church continuing,
to draw people on Sundays and two religious holidays and that,
uh,
in the,
in,
which was the case in,
in our village,
um,
in and our,
our village had a priest,
uh,
the last one who was,
denigrated as a red haired ladies man by son of his,
some of his enemies.
Um,
he left,
I think we got there 20 years ago,
so about four years before we were there.
And as I said the other day in the context of the schools,
uh,
the Catholic church now is just a voluntary association in our particular,
part of France.
Like any other one.
Uh,
there are no more people from our village who go to that church.
Then we'll turn up at,
you know,
x to play Bingo for the,
uh,
for the school,
far fewer,
uh,
from that point of view.
But it doesn't mean that the church doesn't have some place in the collective
memory of the place.
Even a lot of it is imaginary or some of his imaginary,
uh,
once there was a huge windstorm as they're frequently is.
And W we always have these rivers,
right.
When a 22nd of September,
15 years ago,
the river rose so dramatically,
it killed about 200 people,
not in our part in our particular river,
but,
uh,
across the Rhone.
Um,
when a big storm came in,
the statute is rather ugly.
Statue of the Virgin Mary crashed to the ground and broke into a hundred pieces
or a thousand pieces in the cafe that's open all year.
They put up a bowl and people who are very anticlerical always putting money
into the bowl to,
to rebuild this church p rebuild the statute because people care that this
voluntary association remain and that and that it's still a,
in the Catholic church,
you call them four wheel Catholics,
people still will go there for baptism,
for burial or not in this order and for marriage.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I,
I have assisted at,
uh,
with my family,
a combined baptism marriage ceremonies,
uh,
and where the,
you know,
the,
a couple of we'll marry years and years after,
uh,
after having children,
which is pretty usual.
It actually in our part of France among many of our,
uh,
many of our friends and they're still very much couples,
had just never gotten married,
uh,
in France,
in Paris,
in the 19th century.
A quarter of all couples have lived together,
weren't actually married,
but it weren't,
it wasn't that they were just define organized religion is that didn't have
money to pay,
to have a marriage.
And,
and you know,
if you've ever read [inaudible] at when they do get married to well,
as one of his other great novels when they go to them,
the Louvre,
it's one of the great scenes in,
uh,
in French literature,
so far as I know.
Uh,
so,
but the trouble with the Catholic Church,
uh,
in,
in Francis,
of course there's no priests anymore and just end with there that something like
I read it in the bay or one of the newspapers that,
um,
well over half of all the priests in France now are,
uh,
oh,
65% of them are over 60 years old and something like 45% or over 70.
And there are almost no religious vocations at all,
even from religious areas now.
So because churches do provide,
you know,
charity still and help organize lives for very elderly people.
This is very sad.
Uh,
and even Voltaire who once said that if God didn't exist,
he should be invented.
He or she should be invented so that he wouldn't be cheated by his wife or his
Taylor.
Even Voltaire would have agreed,
uh,
that the church,
a church is still,
uh,
in France fill some useful function.
But these regional contracts are still extraordinarily important.
In d Christianization helped define,
uh,
the evolving politics of labelle phones.
Apologies again for this colossal mess about the room.
Uh,
we will take care of this as soon as possible,
like in the next 10 minutes.
Uh,
so,
uh,
have a great weekend and have fun in sections.
See it.